getting excited oh come on it's her
birthday
I'm your welcoming committee this is my
daughter Chelsea she's into gymnastics
too this place is incredible
welcome to Havenhurst don't the last
time you went out for the girls I'm
gonna do whatever I need to do to get
you to have fun I was trying so hard to
keep everything together I'm here for
you whatever you need
keep your distance from them it won't
end well it never does
neela clong turn abyss also looks into
you you're really losing it
I'm on your side never gets despiteful
comment ever I have seen and heard
enough mr. Harbinger please am I being
fired the right amount of pressure any
one of us to be pushed into a very dark
place
[Music]
shamea coats everything and everyone
what's going on I think you know exactly
what's going on your daughter I didn't
do it she's off the team
look you're bringing this on yourself
I can't prove most of what Olivia did
well he can make sure it wasn't anyone
ever again
you wanna bully me that's one thing but
these are our daughters lives evil
you